we're also very involved in the
community back in Oklahoma City when
things settled down here in Houston do
you plan to get involved in the Houston
community as well definitely figure out
you know where I can make an impact and
obviously for me it's always about the
the inner city the at-risk youth and
figuring out a way to be able to impact
and inspire those kids and people around
any community so whenever I get a chance
and sit down I'll be able to go through
and talk to the people I need to talk to
to be able to make those impacts you're
obviously very excited about being here
but when you've been in one place for so
long is there any like worry concern or
anything in your head like how will this
go like what um no I'm not worried I
mean obviously it's a change and it's
that's different especially with with
having kids and figuring out what's best
for them I think that's always the main
concern but as for basketball and
everything else as at least of my
worries because I feel I gotta take care
of yourself we come in with the right
mindset they forgot a way to be able to
help the team and everything else to
take care of itself
Russell um you had some procedures at
Starr the offseason how would you say
where you are right now health-wise and
will you be ready to go for training
campus yeah I'll be ready to go a
training camp I'm doing great
taking my time resting as much as I can
cuz we gonna go after it start a season
and not be ready to go Darryl mentioned
just a few minutes ago that he didn't
expect the trade really to go down until
Paul George deal went through you know
was there ever thought even before that
happened that maybe situation in OKC
wasn't gonna work out and the trades
could have been coming in the future
not sure I'm always you know take one
day at a time to figure out the best
situation for me and I'm always figuring
out especially during the summertime
I'm just getting healthy resting and let
management do whatever they think is
best for the organization and obviously
when the Paul George thing happened
there were different things that were
put in a place to come to this decision
so Russell people in Houston have seen
you for years in the back against an
opponent but what can you say that those
of us have only seen you as
an opponent don't know about you
something that you'd like for people to
know that I'm a nice guy I think that's
the biggest thing obviously when I play
the game and I play da squad there's no
I'm going out to compete going out to be
able to to win and I don't care how that
looks and you know I'm always gonna stay
that way but I think off the floor for
me as a that's a huge thing figuring out
and understanding that I am human I'm a
human being I am a good person just so
you guys know and I do care about the
community the team my teammates
everybody I mean I just want to do
whatever I can do to to make sure that
we have a chance to win Russell you've
been a part of some good defensive teams
in Oklahoma City coming here to a team
that likes to switch what would you say
are some of your strengths defensively
and how do you see yourself fitting into
the style of play here um honestly I
think being able to switch one to five
is it's full all offensively it's tough
because I had to deal with it and it's
tough to be able to run a set it's tough
to be able to do different things and
for me my thing were just better help I
think I I can be able to help a lot on
the rebounding in and switching and
finding ways to get on the passing lanes
and maybe can throw a few laughs to
James if we still got it
figure out a way to be able to just
impact and use my athleticism if our
ways to be able to disrupt a game
Russell there's this new trend of duo's
now in the league it went from the big
3s on several teams not a duos are you a
fan of this because you and James do
have previous chemistry do you think
this can work and how do you feel about
this new trend in the league I think
it's interesting but I don't really care
about the other duo's or other teams
honestly I think that my main focus is
to worry about what we have going on
here and that's all I can worry about